my name is Rob Riggle Schofield I work
for Wolfram and I am giving a talk this
afternoon called wolf sorry mobile CDF
deployment and by mobile what I mean
right now is iOS iPads and iPhones we
have done a fair amount of work on
Android support for all the stuff that
I'm going to be showing today but it's
quite a ways behind where our iOS
developments are so I'm not going to be
showing anything there so if you have
been to this conference the last several
years I have given a talk at this
conference with a similar title so I've
given this talk a few times what's
different this year from the previous
years so in the previous years I gave
this talk i was showing technology that
we have been working on that didn't
necessarily have a product to go along
with it this year i'm only going to be
showing products so there's three
different things that we're going to
look at one of them has already shipped
and two of them will be shipping very
soon so I'm fairly confident that next
year at this conference I won't be
giving the exact same talk and that
makes me feel a lot better so you can
now and very soon deploy your CDF
content to mobile devices using either
Wolfram's apps or your own app and I'm
going to explain how to do that so the
first thing I'm going to mention is
Wolfram cloud and I'm not going to go
too far into Wolfram cloud because there
is a separate talk that is dedicated
solely to Wolfram cloud at later this
afternoon I'll just highlight a few
interesting things about it so Wolfram
cloud is available now for iOS you can
go to the App Store and you can get it
you can download it for free you can log
in using your wolf own cloud account all
your documents will be there and you can
open them view them you can even edit
them so that's one of the the neat
things Wolfram cloud app has going for
it you can
eight and edit documents there are some
things about using the cloud which are
actually advantageous when you're
talking about interacting with mobile
device so if you're doing computations
that require a lot of CPU or a lot of
RAM doing in the cloud is probably
better and if you don't have the CPU
constantly spinning on your computations
the battery life on your mobile device
will last longer in those cases and it
has a very small download size since
it's basically just a really thin client
that calls out to the cloud to do a lot
of the heavy lifting so it does have a
few limitations that all I'll just
briefly mention it does require a
network connection since it's rico it
relies solely on the cloud for all the
document viewing and computation support
and the interactivity is a little bit
limited in that for example if you're
doing and manipulate or rotating
rotating a 3d graphic those sorts of
things do need to communicate to the
server over the network and that takes a
little bit of time so it's not quite as
a smooth experiences it would be if it
was all running locally on your device
so if you want to learn more about
Wolfram cloud there's a talk at
four-thirty today that my colleague Nick
will be giving you haven't met Nick he
is sort of grayish and not well defined
next is Wolfram player this is an app
that there was a lot of back and forth
about and we received a lot of feedback
from our users our users say said we
want a Wolfram player app for iOS and we
have decided that we are going to build
that we have been working very hard on
it and it will be released soon we hope
to release it by the end of this year so
definitely in time for next year's tech
conference so this is an app that we
plan to make available for free just as
the Wolfram player apps are free on
desktop systems and you will be able to
use it to view CDF documents step the if
you have static content like what I'm
looking at now you you can just view
that in the app for free if you have
Enterprise CDF documents that were
created from your actually don't know
exactly how that works but if you have
Enterprise CDF you know what that means
and you can create CDF documents that
you can distribute and people will be
able to use the free Wolfram player app
to do interactive things with those
documents so if you have dynamic content
you have manipulates you should be able
to do those for free with Wolfram player
app and then we're going to have an
optional in-app purchase for a
reasonable price to enable full dynamic
interactivity for arbitrary CDF
documents so stuff that doesn't that's
not enterprise CDF maybe stuff that you
just create on your desktop machine and
you want to carry it around with you in
your pocket or in your backpack that
will just be a an optional in-app
purchase to get dynamic interactivity
for those documents so Wolfram player is
a native app so it has a user interface
and user experience that's appropriate
for the platform whether that be I are
at iOS soon or Android a little bit
further off it has a Wolfram engine
embedded inside of the app so all the
computations are done locally and that
allows for a much better interactive
experience well from player supports all
the CDF content you would expect we have
nice typesetting and this is all we can
zoom into this and it still looks really
nice these aren't bitmaps we have to
dear affix
we have 3d graphics including
transparency and these are live you can
rotate them I'm just touching this with
my finger and kind of spinning it around
here and one of the neat things that
we've done on iOS is that we allow
tossing gestures so I can take this and
spin it really fast and just let it go
and it will kind of spin around for a
little while dynamic we have controls
and everything that has dynamic or all
of your the content that uses dynamic
will update appropriately when these
dynamic values change manipulate and
this is something that we had to do a
little bit differently than what we do
on desktop systems as I'm sure most of
you are familiar when you have a
manipulate command in desktop version of
Mathematica by default you get a bunch
of controls right above your content and
you can use your mouse to interact with
those controls if we place those above
the content on a touchscreen device your
hand is going to be blocking the content
that you're trying to look at so what we
do here by default and there's ways to
override this if you really want to we
tap on it to activate it and we slide up
some controls from the bottom of the
screen this one just has a single slider
and we can interact with a slider down
here without blocking the view of the
the content that we're working with and
then when you're done we can just tap
away in the controls slide off screen so
this version of Wolfram player is built
for touchscreens so on a desktop system
we have functions like mouse position
which don't make a lot of sense on an
iPad that I'm using here so we have a
new function called touch position that
allows you to do the same sorts of
things is mount you can with mouse
position on a desktop but it's a little
bit more flexible since you know right
now I'm not touching the screen there's
no touch
is the it just returns an empty list and
this is the thing with the green
background here so if I put a finger
down I get a point I put two fingers
down two points and I can keep loading
this up with a bunch of fingers here and
this works even while you know I'm
scrolling the document it's still
working so in addition to touch position
we have a function called gesture
handler which is very similar to what
event handler does on a desktop
mathematica one of the gestures we
support is a drag gesture so I just have
a simple example here where I turned off
I disabled a 3d rotation and i'm using
this drag gesture to adjust the radius
of the sphere here so you can do some
neat interactive things using gesture
handler and if if you have certain types
of controls like a vertical slider for
example if we pop up a vertical slider
from the bottom of the screen it's going
to cover half the screen so we have a
new option to manipulate called
touchscreen control placement for cases
like this where you can move the
controls over to the right side of the
screen or the left or the top or the
bottom you can specify where you want
the controls and so I have my vertical
slider over on the right here where it's
not taking up as much space as it would
at the bottom
okay so what are some of the limitations
we encounter when deploying CDF to iOS
so we have a relatively large download
size this is only going to affect you
once probably but it's a it's a few
hundred megabytes it does include the
full Wolfram engine and there's really
not any way to get around that so you're
not gonna be able to download it over
cellular connection but download it over
Wi-Fi and just keep it on your device
and you should be good so this is a
player app so the documents are
read-only this app doesn't allow editing
documents there's a handful of features
which are incomplete and will be
incomplete for the first you know for
the near future things like event
handler you know we're just not going to
support a lot of the types of events you
get on a desktop system tab you isn't
implemented there's certain cases of
locator that aren't implemented there's
limitations with input field it doesn't
support arbitrary 2d typeset content
it's just linear linear text input for
input field j link which requires a java
runtime is not available on iOS so we
have no j-link support and other
features which are built on top of
jailing things like database link these
are not going to be possible due to the
lack of G link there's some performance
considerations to to take into account
the older iOS devices in particular are
very have very small amount of RAM so
it's kind of a big deal just to get you
know Wolfram engine running at all with
such a small amount of RAM and you know
whatever computations you do on top of
that it's just going to you know add to
the need for memory so we try to handle
low memory situations gracefully
sometimes there's not a lot we can do
vos iOS will just sometimes abruptly
kill the app if it's using too much
memory but we try to avoid that whenever
we can the newer devices have a little
bit more RAM so it's less of an issue
with an ipad air or an ipad air to the
cpu is you know ferret fairly slow by
the standards of desktops and laptops
that we're used to working with i think
i mentioned a few years ago when i gave
this talk the mobile performance is
about five years behind where desktops
and laptops were at this point it's
actually slightly less they're probably
closer to three to four years behind I
got a new iphone 6s a few weeks ago and
I ran benchmarks on it and it's faster
than my macbook air from 2012 so they're
catching up which is which is
interesting other limitations the
Wolfram engine cannot currently be
restarted like you can in a desktop
version of mathematica you can go to the
menu and quit colonel we can't do that
so if for some reason that becomes
necessary you'll have to quit the entire
app and then start it up again so next
I'm going to talk about something called
CDF kit in CDF kit is an SDK that we are
making for iOS CDF kit is actually the
core of the Wolfram player app so if we
look at what's on the screen right now
the the dark bar across the top that's
the CDF player app and then everything
else on screen that's CDF kid and so
this is something that we use internally
for our apps and this is something that
we are going to be making available to
partners to build custom apps with as
well we already have a few partners who
are testing it at the moment and around
probably around the time when we release
the player app we will start making this
available more widely to more partners
so if you are interested in building a
custom app come see us and we'll we'll
see if we can work something out so
clients can embed cdf get into their iOS
apps and that will allow you to display
CDF content including interactive things
like 3d graphics dynamic manipulate you
can also use it to perform evaluations
using Wolfram language expressions so
even if you're not necessarily
displaying CDF content but you have a
chunk of Wolfram language code that you
just want to evaluate you can do that
even if you're not displaying anything
so there's a concise interface it's
fairly small fairly easy to wrap your
head around that you can call from your
objective c or swift app on iOS so this
isn't a this isn't a one hundred percent
solution there will be you will need to
write a little bit of code in
objective-c or Swift in order to take
advantage of the CDF kit SDK so there's
several different types of applications
that this will enable so in this
application the CDF content is basically
taking over the entire screen and we
have more content than displays in one
screen full so it Scrolls that's one
thing that we can do you can also have a
completely custom interface that just
has a tiny rectangle somewhere on the
screen that has CDF content inside of it
so what we're looking at here this is
the Wolfram player app that we're going
to be releasing soon and it is built
using CDF get we also have in
development we are working on a version
of the wolfram alpha app that uses CDF
kit and I don't know if and when that's
going to be available but hopefully
we'll have something like that and I'll
just give you a brief demonstration of
how that works
so this is my special version of the
wolfram alpha app and I have normal
wolframalpha output with this little
button here that I'm just going to tap
on and now what was once a static
Wolfram Alpha output is now interactive
and while I'm here I'm just going to
briefly show the Wolfram cloud app in
case you're not familiar with that these
are my cloud documents and I have the
same document that we were looking at in
the Wolfram player app and this takes a
couple seconds to open up here but this
is all running in the cloud this is a
very small app and there are features
that I can use to edit this document
which you'll you'll see a knicks talk if
you if you go to that so back in Wolfram
player I will just show you real quick
this was a file that was stored locally
on my iPad so I didn't need any network
connectivity to use that but we can also
access files stored in the wolfman cloud
and so this is that same list of files
that we just looked at in the Wolfram
cloud app but it's in Wolfram player and
I can open this same document and
everything just works as you would
expect